vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
printemps que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
pas de confinement prolongé pour les
seniors en france à partir du 11 mai
prochain déclarations des manuels mâcon
qui est revenu sur celle de lundi il dit
ne pas souhaiter discriminer une partie
des français l'exécutif lui réfléchit
sur les modalités de sault déconfinement
progressif le premier ministre doit
s'exprimer demain et puis sachez que sur
le plan économique l'assemblée nationale
a approuvé la nuit dernière
le nouveau budget de crise qui s'élève à
112 milliards d'euros
le fonds monétaire international et la
banque mondiale appelle à soutenir
l'afrique faute de ressources et
d'infrastructures médicales pour lutter
contre la crise sanitaire le continent a
besoin d'au moins 114 milliards de
dollars pour répondre à des besoins
financiers urgents la barre du millier
de morts a été atteinte vendredi la
pandémie peut encore être contenue selon
l' oms à contre courant aux états unis
les protestations anti
man se multiplient elles sont même
encouragés par le président lui-même
donald trump a appelé les américains je
cite à libérer trois états dirigés par
des démocrates états dans lesquels les
manifestants réclament une levée des
restrictions
objectif affiché par le chef de la
maison blanche la reprise de l'économie
[Musique]
d
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce soir le président
français qui écarte finalement le
confinement prolongé pour les seniors à
partir du 11 mai prochain emmanuel
macron a préféré éteindre la polémique
sans attendre la conférence de presse du
premier ministre prévue demain à 17
heures le président de la république qui
dit ne pas souhaiter discriminer les
personnes âgées il en appelle donc à la
responsabilité individuelle de chacun ah
c'est ce qu'a précisé l'élysée hier soir
lors de son dernier discours pourtant
emmanuel macron avait demandé aux
personnes les plus vulnérables et aux
personnes âgées de rester confinés même
après le 11 mai écoutez la réaction des
principaux concernés
soixante dix ans est en forme on est
encore très bonne idée et on peut rendre
service c'est ça le problème
et il ya une majorité de personnes de
plus de 70 ans qui vont rendre service
on en a besoin des anciens ils ont
besoin les jeunes voilà c'est pour ça
que c'est important d'y réfléchir
je pense qu'on est tous responsables et
je pense à partir du moment où on a des
problèmes de santé on doit effectivement
resté confiné mais on est suffisamment
grand pour le comprendre comment on
trouve que c'est quand même assez d'être
discriminatoire parce que là aujourd'hui
on n'a pas de
de retour sur
dirait la contagion entre les seniors
qui sont entre guillemets rivalité qui
ne sont pas du tout malade et ceux qui
ont des grosses pathologies et on nous
met tous à la même enseigne sachant qu'à
65 ans on nous dit qu'on peut travailler
plus longtemps parce que ronald
espérance de vie est plus longue
donc il ya un discours qui est un petit
peu qu'on va dire anachronique on a du
mal à comprendre
la france qui compte 6 142 morts de plus
ces dernières 24 heures + 20 % de décès
depuis début mars par rapport à l'an
dernier
c'est ce que révèle la dernière étude de
l'insee publiée hier une surmortalité
qui est lié bien sûr à l'épidémie de
corps d'un virus mais vous allez devoir
les régions et les départements ne sont
pas tous impactés de la même manière
[Musique]
mais
on
il
[Musique]
et l'année dernière l'assemblée
nationale a voté le nouveau budget de
crise d'un montant de 112 milliards
d'euros un budget pour soutenir les
entreprises aidées les plus modestes
donner une prime aux soignants mais
aussi pour élargir le dispositif de
chômage partiel est aussi financé
l'achat de masques dits grand public
ce second projet de loi de finances doit
encore être présenté au sénat mardi
prochain le conseil d'état a limité le
pouvoir des maires de france il a annulé
l'obligation du port du masque décidé
dans la ville de sceaux en région
parisienne les maires ne peuvent plus
donc de leur propre initiative prendre
d'autres mesures que celles décidées par
l'état
c'est ce qu'a jugé hier la plus haute
juridiction administrative juridiction
qui a estimé également que l'arrêté du
maire de sceaux risque et je cite de
nuire à la cohérence des mesures prises
dans l'intérêt de la santé publique par
les autorités sanitaires compétentes
fin de citation oui et ce qu'on dit
philippe laurent lemaire udi de la ville
de sont justement je pense que ces
mesures ne sont pas suffisantes
je pense que dès le départ il fallait
donc demandé à chacune et à chacun de se
protéger d éviter au maximum des maîtres
donc ce fameux nuage des postillons dont
on sait qu'il est le vecteur privilégié
de transmission du virus
ça c'est la première chose je pense que
c'était une erreur majeure de dire des
débuts que le port d'un masque et est
inutile est vraiment une erreur majeure
je comprends pour psa a été fait parce
qu'il n'avait pas suffisamment de masse
industriels pour être distribués à la
population en même temps qu aux
soignants et un après vie des soignants
a eu raison mais il fallait pas dire que
le masque était inutile fallait dire on
en a pas assez
on va en fabriquer en faire fabriquer
etc mais en tout cas en attendant
protégez vous il compterait avec un
masque artisanales comme celui qui est
sur l'image lactée leaké sur votre écran
et donc il fallait vraiment faire cela
je trouve que là c était une erreur
presque une faute qui a probablement y
ait un certain nombre de personnes
contaminées en plus et qui a provoqué
dans 42 morts supplémentaires
et c'est là où je suis je suis stupéfait
si vous voulez d'altitude n'ont pas dû
concéder finalement mais surtout du
gouvernement
mr qui sont en première ligne face aux
craintes de leurs administrés qui
tentons la vue de tant de trouver des
solutions afin de les rassurer
à reims on se prépare déjà au
déconfinement du 11 mai prochain et vous
allez le voir
la police municipale est à pied d'oeuvre
mais pas pour dresser des contraventions
cette fois le reportage est signée
estelle farge et cynthia lauvergeon
c'est une tournée inhabituel que
s'apprête à entamer ces trois policiers
municipaux les 730 535 recrue spa
continue la mission réduite de masquer
les trois jours qui sillonnent reims
équipés de boîtes de masques pour les
distribuer aux commerces de première
nécessité restés ouverts
première cible de la journée cette
épicerie de quartier la mairie de reims
mais pour tous les commerces de
proximité
hier donc boîte de 50 points
c'est pour nous
commerces de proximité forcément vous
êtes en droit
l'initiative est plutôt bien accueillie
chez les commerçants on a vu
l'information sur le facebook du maire
comme quoi la police municipale allait
passer ça rassure à mon petit peur
personnellement je suis pas sûr de m je
respecte vraiment bien la distance avec
les clients
je connais toi bien les vins et pour moi
pour l'instant c'est suffisant en tout
la police municipale a distribué une
boîte de 50 masques à 280 établissements
de la ville une opération à l'initiative
de la mairie dans le but non seulement
de protéger des commerçants mais aussi
de préparer le déconfinement elle était
novembre la collectivité de pouvoir leur
proposer des équipements de protection
pour les protéger protéger leurs
salariés bien évidemment le but c'est
d'élargir et notamment de préparer ce
onze mecs n'est pas le des confinement
total à un objectif que s'est donné le
gouvernement et donc nous allons en tout
recevoir plus d'un million de masques
ce qui va nous permettre de d'équiper
chaque rémois d'un masque pas un premier
temps des masques chirurgicaux en
attendant l'arrivée de la commande des
masques dits au grand public donc c'est
masque en tissu qui seront également
distribuées à chaque habitant de la
ville
après les commerçants les assistantes
maternelles devraient être les
prochaines a bénéficié de ces
distribution de masques à reims le
gouvernement français qui a peut-être
déjà perdu la bataille de la confiance
c'est ce qui ressort d'un sondage paru
dans le quotidien le monde le moral des
français est leur confiance en exécutif
ont été affectés par cette crise du
coronavirus un phénomène d'ailleurs bien
plus marquée en france qu'en allemagne
au royaume-uni
32% des sondés vous le voyez évoque de
la méfiance 28% de la morosité et 27%
même de la peur des chiffres qui sont en
augmentation depuis le mois de février
voyez ce qu'en dit alexis poulain
cofondateur du monde moderne que la
parole politique est totalement
déconsidéré parce qu'il ya eu trop de
mensonges et que effectivement on peut
entendre un discours c'est toujours bien
mais ce qui compte c'est les actes et en
particulier avec haendel macron souvent
les discours sont loin voire à l'opposé
des actes typiquement il parle de
solidarité européenne et le groupe new
dont fait partie en marche bien va voter
au parlement européen contre les corona
bones contre une solidarité européenne
de fait il ya des annonces qui sont
faites sur l'aide à l'afrique et puis le
lendemain on parle d'un moratoire à la
dette plutôt que d'annuler la dette
donc on navigue à vue et puis cette
façon de gouverner qui devrait inquiéter
tout le monde dans la solitude dans les
seulement il n'a prévenu que très peu de
gens autour de son entourage le premier
ministre olivier véran à propos de la
date du 11 mai on ne sait pas d'où elle
sort d'où elle vient
alors il ya peut-être le conseil
scientifique qui est là pour l'aider à
prendre des décisions mais c'est un
grand pays la france ça ne peut pas être
géré depuis le bureau d'un seul homme à
l'elysée par manque de moyens oui oui
par manque de moyens absolument par
manque de moyens parce qu on est
incapable d'organiser un déconfinement
dans le calme et l'assurance d'une
sécurité maximale pour tous sachant
qu'on va devoir vivre avec ce lieu je le
répète c'est à dire que quand on va
sortir le virus sera encore là il y aura
d'autres poches le commerce
international va reprendre les voyages
vont reprendre on ne sait pas à quel
horizon mais le monde va être différent
parce que le corps d'un virus va être là
et qu'il y aura d'autres sans doute
d'autres virus la couronne qui risque
d'arriver d'autres pandémies celle ci
est la première donc c'est un peu un
test pour voir comment ça fonctionne
or on voit d'autres pays qui gère
beaucoup mieux parce qu'ils ont un
système de santé qui est mieux préparé
parce qu'ils se sont mieux préparés
aussi dans la façon de gérer les
populations et en france il se tout
serait la faute des français qui
seraient incapables de mettre des
masques qui ne savent pas comment faire
mais en même temps regarder comment les
ordres les injonctions sont
contradictoires aux plus hauts sommets
les pharmaciens qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi ils ne peuvent pas vendre des
masques ou en donner les masques on ne
sait toujours pas où ils sont et le
problème il est là au fond on n'organise
pas une réponse à la hauteur de la crise
et dans ce contexte de confinement la
mère la mère de paris interpelle le
ministre de l'intérieur sur l'insécurité
dans certains quartiers de paris anne
hidalgo qui s'inquiète notamment de la
délinquance dans certains quartiers du
nord-est de la capitale
elle a donc dressé a adressé un courrier
à christophe castaner pour lui demander
davantage de policiers sur le terrain
vous voyez ce qu'en dit rocco contento
secrétaire départemental paris unité sgp
police les policiers sont présents font
leur travail
il est vrai que nous n'avons pas une
ressource inépuisable
il serait heureux d'avoir des policiers
supplémentaires pour faire continuer à
faire ses patrouilles et ce travail
néanmoins pendant cette période assez
compliquée parce que je vous le dis ça
en pensant des policiers sont confinés à
domicile vous avez des collègues
beaucoup de collègues qui vont qui sont
suspectés d'avoir le
19 qui ne sont pas testés et qui sont
aussi mis en 14 et d'un domicile
et puis voilà il faut dire aussi que le
maire de paris c'est une femme politique
c'est pas la première fois qu'ils aient
de ce genre d'argument envers le prévenu
de l'intérieur puisqu'il nous a pas
échappé que elle elle veut absolument
mettre en place sa police municipale à
paris qui devait être effective en
janvier mais qui avait été retoqué par
l'assemblée nationale donc aussi le le
fait de faire des sorties comme ça pour
elle sa légitime la mise en place de sa
police municipale à paris à la halle au
royaume uni a dépassé la barre des
quinze mille morts et comme en france il
y a une réelle inquiétude dans les
maisons de retraite où le bilan pourrait
être beaucoup plus lourd médias ce qui
fit des centaines de décès
supplémentaires constatés toutes les 24
heures déjà très lourd le bilan humain
annoncé par les autorités britanniques
ne prend en compte que les décès à
l'hôpital sans comptabiliser ceux des
établissements pour personnes âgées
selon karine grind un organisme qui
représente les maisons de retraite
indépendante près de 7500 personnes
seraient mortes dans ces résidences pour
seniors
bien loin des 217 dénombrés par le
bureau des statistiques nationales
certains responsables du secteur déplore
cette situation nous avons plusieurs
résidants dans 10 de nos quinze maisons
de retraite qui ont des symptômes
ressemblant à des symptômes du kobe 19
le problème c'est que nous n'avons pas
accès à des dépistages pour eux nous
commençons à peine à obtenir des
dépistages pour notre personnel soignant
dans les maisons de retraite mais c'est
loin d'être le cas pour les résidents à
l'heure actuelle les maisons de retraite
sont en première ligne pendant de
nombreuses années notre secteur a été
négligée mais à présent nous sommes en
première ligne dans la lutte contre le
coc vie 19 et nous avons besoin de plus
de soutien de la part du gouvernement
certaines personnes âgées parviennent
néanmoins combattre le coït 19 comme
cette patiente de 106 ans prise en
charge à burning
ham après trois semaines
d'hospitalisation vous vous souvenez ce
matin nous discutions et vous vous
souvenez que je vous ai dit que vous
étiez la personne la plus âgée à
survivre à ce méchant virus qui circule
au oui selon public allthings les
autorités de santé locales 3084 maison
de retraite en angleterre compter des
cas de coronavirus à la date du 15 avril
interrogé sur cet épineux dossier le
ministre britannique de la santé matin
coque reconnaît que le nombre réel de
morts est plus grand il assure qu'un
bilan officiel sera publié dans les
prochains jours et l'italie enregistre
son plus faible nombre de morts
quotidiens depuis six jours maintenant
d'après le bilan quotidien communiqué
aujourd'hui l'épidémie de kobe de 19 à
fait 480 de morts de plus dans le pays
et bien que toujours élevé c'est le plus
fait la plus faible augmentation
journalière depuis le 12 avril
le nombre de nouveaux cas officiel lui
reste sable de jour en jour
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
préoccupé par la progression de la
pandémie sur le continent africain le
nombre de morts a dépassé le millier
avec un grand nombre de décès notamment
pour l'algérie l'egypte le maroc ou
l'afrique du sud
selon l'organisation mondiale de la
santé il y avait eu une hausse de 51
pour cent du nombre de cas recensés et
graisser 11 ans et 60% l'ouest estime
toutefois qu'elle ce stade la maladie
peut toujours être contenue elle a
rappelé que les pays d'afrique avait
besoin notamment de ressources et
d'équipements la banque mondiale et le
fmi ont aussi indiqué qu'ils manquaient
44 milliards de dollars au continent
afin de lutter contre cette pandémie
quel rôle joue exactement l' oms dans la
gestion de cette crise sanitaire peut
être d'être fragilisée par la suspension
du financement américain voyez ce qu'on
dit pascal boniface géopolitologue
qu'elle fait à la fois de réseaux
dallaire de réseaux d'information du
réseau également de communication son
rôle est essentiel parce qu'elle a une
expertise technique qui est extrêmement
élevé
une fois encore elle n'est pas on n'est
pas dans un système supranationale et
donc elle ne peut pas imposer des
mesures quelles qu'elles soient
les zetas et aux états chacun de la
brenne dit souverain de prendre les
décisions qu'ils veulent pour contenir
la pandémie il états unis pourront être
accusé directement et indirectement dans
l'assistance à ivan était en danger
puisque il réduit les moyens de l'om est
ce au moment où celle ci est plus
dangereux que jamais et puis tout
simplement si l'om est gardé les mêmes
moyens
c'est que d'autres pays au rêve serait
venu remplir le vide laissé par les
états unis
et donc c est là aussi fidèlement les
états unis qui seraient perdants mais
une fois encore on plie ans doit situer
tout ceci dans un contexte général
électoral est dans un système aussi au
trump s'attaque systématiquement à
toutes les institutions internationales
il a retiré les camions de l'unesco il
s'est retiré de l'accord sur nucléaire
iranien il fait retirer de l'accord de
paris sur la protection du climat
trump veut s'attaquer à l'ensemble du
système kuti latéral aux états unis
alors que le pays compte 4400 nouveaux
décès en 24 heures les manifestations
anti confinement se multiplient après
notamment l appel lancé par donald trump
le président américain leur a demandé je
cite de libérer trois états le michigan
le minnesota et la virginie trois états
démocrate
clément hospital à l'entrée de la
résidence du gouverneur du minnesota
quelques 2000 manifestants défient
l'ordre de rester chez eux
pancartes à la main et drapeau américain
sur les épaules ils protestent contre
les mesures de confinement et appellent
leur gouvernement à ouvrir l'économie
gouverneur walt fait quelque chose pour
nous les travailleurs indépendants les
gens qui n'ont reçu aucune aide
financière pour quoi que ce soit aidez
nous nous sommes ici car nous voulons
travailler dans une demi douzaine
d'états ces derniers jours les
rassemblements se sont multipliées
contre les mesures de distanciation
sociale et on soutient donald trump pour
qu'il est temps de faire redémarrer
l'amérique en pleine crise sanitaire
le président américain a ciblé trois
états dirigés par des gouverneurs
démocrates appelant à libérer le
minnesota
le michigan ou encore la virginie il ya
encore quelques jours
donald trump appelé les états à prendre
des mesures au cas par cas
les gouverneurs seront habilités à
adopter une approche qui répond aux
diverses caractéristiques de leur propre
état
chaque état est très différent ils sont
tous beaux nous les aimons tous mais ils
sont très très différent s'ils doivent
rester fermés nous leur permettrons de
le faire et s'il croit qu'il est temps
de rouvrir
nous leur donnerons la liberté les
conseils pour accomplir cette tâche est
très très rapidement en fonction de ce
qu'ils voudront faire le dirigeant du
minnesota tim roth s'est défendu en
rappelant que sa première responsabilité
est de protéger la population
le camp démocrate dénonce
l'irresponsabilité de ces tweets
présidentielle je sais que la pandémie
de kobe 19 pèse lourdement sur notre
économie et la vie de tous les
virginiens et je veux que nous arrivions
à une situation dans laquelle les
entreprises pourront rouvrir nous allons
y arriver mais nous devons le faire en
recourant à la science aux données et
aux tests et nous devons nous assurer de
le faire en toute sécurité
les déclarations du président ce matin
encourage des actes illégaux et
dangereux
il fait courir à des millions de
personnes le risque de contracter le
qu'ovide 19 ses vociférations
incontrôlée et ses appels à libérer des
états pourrait également provoquer des
violences nous avons déjà vu ce genre de
chose du colorado omnium chaleur en
passant par le texas
de nouvelles manifestations sont prévues
tout au long de la journée et pour
jean-paul chang économiste la santé
économique de la chine pourrait dépendre
de la situation des marchés
internationaux
j'ai entendu dire par exemple que le
texas voulait être le premier est à
réouvrir entre guillemets aux états unis
mais là aussi se fera je pense d'une
manière très progressive
chaque état est un état qui est quand
même indépendant avec des lois
différentes avec des systèmes ou si
sanitaire et de santé qui sont
différents
sonder les gouverneurs sont des
personnes qui sont élus je pense qu'ils
ont plutôt intérêt la bonne santé de
leurs populations
plutôt que de prendre des risques et
après dans un deuxième temps être obligé
de se re confiné à cause d'une deuxième
vague qui pourrait être dramatique parce
que le système pourrait sanitaire
pourrait être complètement débordés in
all its médecin français qui vit aux
états unis et non pas monsieur chang de
la chine la chine
il en est question à présent le produit
intérieur brut du pays en recul de près
de 7%
c'est son plus mauvais résultat depuis
la fin de mao la région du hubei est
resté confiné soixante quinze jours
l'équipe l'économie du pays a fortement
ralenti l'activité reprend
progressivement mais cette reprise est
plus lente que prévu puisque les
millions de chinois doivent encore
réduire leurs déplacements ce qui
ralentit évidemment elle la consommation
écouter à présent jean paul chang
économiste et pour lui la santé
économique de la chine pourrait dépendre
de la situation des marchés
internationaux
je pense que dans la deuxième moitié de
2020 les choses ils ont déjà beaucoup
mieux en 2021
parce que s'ils créent un peu liées à la
conjoncture internationale
certes le commerce international ne
représente pas une part prépondérante de
la croissance chinoise
mais la chine dépend quand même de la
conjoncture internationale il faut voir
que la croissance chinoise répondre à
peu près à hauteur de 10% du commerce
international de doubler ses
exportations
et là dessus l'incertitude qui règne sur
les marchés américain et européen est
pénalisant bientôt de bien sûr pour pour
la croissance chinoise
allez on termine avec ces images
insolites à travers le monde et vous
allez le voir la population ne manque
pas d'idées pour casser l'ennui du
confinement
[Musique]
oh
vaincus shine
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même
[Musique]
quand
[Rires]
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité sur notre antenne on se
retrouve dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coups politiques n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent
françois vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation en france une quinzaine
de zones ont été sélectionnés dans les
années 90 par des militants dieu la
première erreur de notes administration
a été de croire que les terroristes
étaient des loups solitaires alors
qu'ils étaient la résultante de 15 ans
de travail de fond fait par les
analystes
soyons clairs ils ont prêché la guerre
sainte et le problème c'est qu'on les a
trop longtemps les échos il ya eu un
espèce de déni de réalité et la famille
drame d'une attaque ans pour qu'il y ait
enfin une reconnaissance générale de la
situation dans notre pays
la ministre de la justice madame
belloubet annonce la sortie en 2020 de
43 du à 10 140 avant fin 2022 sur les
531 incarcéré aujourd'hui
qui peut croire que la majeure partie
ces individus mus par la haine de la
france est désormais libre ne sont pas
un défi pour la sécurité nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
360 millions d'euros vont être affectés
à la lutte contre les violences mais
finalement ce n'est pas plus que l'an
dernier
au niveau des mesures on vous annonce
beaucoup de choses qui existent déjà qui
ne fonctionne pas pour preuve 138
victimes
le gouvernement ne nous entend pas le
gouvernement ne nous voit pas dans notre
association en trois mesures qu'on
demande au gouvernement
c'est un les priver de liberté donc avec
le bras serait anti rapprochement de les
toucher au porte-monnaie les foyers ça
va être à leur charge et 3 les priver de
leurs droits parentaux vous allez
continuez à vous battre
on ne va pas lâcher bien sûr
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission qui ne porte pas de masque
d'abord parce qu'on en a pas et ensuite
parce qu'on ne saurait pas les mettre
bonjour aujourd'hui on va vous parler du
pétrole
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous ravis de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de sc cash et l'émission
qui s'adapte bien évidemment aux mesures
de confinement c'est pour cela olivier
que vous n'êtes pas en plateau à maison
duplex confiné chez vous alors au
sommaire de cette émission vous l'avez
dit on va parler du pétrole la pandémie
de coronavirus a heurté de plein fouet
le secteur pétrolier les pays
producteurs n'arrivent plus à écouler
leur or noir face à la baisse de la
demande
pendant ce temps les cours du pétrole
ont plongé pour la première fois depuis
2002 le baril le prix du baril américain
est tombé sous la barre des 20 dollars
pour comparaison en début d'année il
oscillait autour de 64 $ même chose pour
le brent qui est passé de 69 à 22 dollar
chute des prix donc mais aussi chute de
la demande puisque elle devrait reculer
de 20 à 30 % au deuxième trimestre à
leurs oliviers est ce que c'est une
catastrophe selon vous et quelles
conséquences ces chutes en pagaille
vont-elles provoqué alors c'est une
catastrophe pour les américains
notamment
pourquoi en tout cas c'est une
catastrophe pour tout les pétrole qui
sont chers à sortie c'est à dire le
pétrole issu des des bitumes du canada
et puis le pétrole de schiste américain
ensuite vous avez un peu moins cher à
sortir vous avez lé pétrole qui sont
deux des pétrole offshore
forer en eaux profondes qui sont entre
30 et 40 dollars de coûts de production
vous avez pétrole russe qui est à 19
dollars et vous avez le pétrole du golfe
qui est entre 6 et 7 dollars à peu près
les pétroles de schiste en revanche
c'est entre 50 et 70 dollars donc
évidemment aujourd'hui à chaque fois
qu'ils sortent un baril de pétrole et
ils perdent une quarantaine de dollars
sur chaque baril évidemment ça risque de
ne pas durer très très longtemps et
aujourd'hui vous avez toute l'industrie
du schiste qui est joyeusement en train
de faire faillite
donc alors c'est pas c'est pas le
coronavirus qui a qui a provoqué sa le
corona virus est arrivé là pour aggraver
les choses c'est à dire pour réduire
encore la demande mais vous aviez une
demande qui parce que les pays était en
récession parce que le commerce mondial
était déjà en train de freiner
il y avait une demande qui était qui
était faible
et puis là dessus quand on a un virus
évidemment en arrêtant les pays
complètement fait que la demande s'est
écoulé et que là le pétrole est allé
comme à chaque récession est allé en
dessous de 30 $ là il a exagéré un peu
il est allé en dessous de 20 $ parce que
à ça à ce problème de demande s'est
rajouté le le problème de l'offre
c'est-à-dire que les russes et et le
l'arabie saoudite principalement ont
refusé de réduire leur production et
donc évidemment à ce moment là vous avez
un gonflement extraordinaire des stocks
comme on en a rarement vu aujourd'hui il
ya des tankers qui font des ronds dans
l'eau pour pour stocker le pétrole
il n'ya plus quasiment de capacité de
stockage terrestre donc évidemment ça
augmente encore plus les prix de puisque
le coût du stockage augmentent
énormément et donc vous avez aujourd'hui
une crise sur le pétrole mais qui va
d'abord toucher les pétrole cher
c'est-à-dire le canada je pense que ils
sont ils sont morts et les états unis
derrière et évidemment ça a des
conséquences économiques énormes pour
les américains alors juste avant la
ligne on va revenir un peu plus tard
dans l'émission sur ces problèmes de
stockage est sûre est cette guerre des
prix entre la russie et l'arabie
saoudite un mot quand même un comble
quand on a concrètement en barils un
baril de pétrole à 20 dollars est-ce que
ça se répercute aussi significativement
sur les prix à la pompe
non ça serait trop facile ça serait trop
beau non bah vous n'avez qu'à regarder
les prix de l'essence alors ont baissé
évidemment enfin on se
on est toujours autour des 1,30 à 1,35
ce qui évidemment ne correspond pas à un
baril de pétrole à 20 dollars mais tout
simplement parce que dans les 1,30 à
1,35
vous avez un euro de taxe 1le donc que
le le vrai coût du pétrole serait de 35
centimes si vous n'aviez pas cessé dax
donc il je pense pas que dans la crise
actuelle
les pays comme la france réduise les
taxes sur le pétrole pour que on le paye
le vrai prix finalement en aucun cas le
consommateur n'a pas de gagnant à bas le
consommateur non il n'est jamais gagnant
c'est le but c'est but d'ailleurs il est
jamais gagnant donc quand vous avez un
pétrole à 100 plus de 100 dollars le
baril je vous rappelle que à ce moment
là le laissant c'était autour de 1,60 1
50-1 60 et maintenant qu'il est à 20
dollars le baril c'est à dire diviser
par 5 ou par six
eh bien vous retrouver avec un pétrole à
un gain d'une essence qui est à 1,30
donc qui n'a pas baissé beaucoup
allez viens pour tenter de limiter la
casse l'opep l'organisation des pays
exportateurs de pétrole s'est réuni le 9
avril autour de ses ailiers de l'accord
opep plus une réunion de crise
exceptionnelle par visioconférence à
laquelle à des pays qui ne font pas
partie de l'organisation ont été
conviées comme les états unis et la
norvège ou encore le canada ils vont
tenter d'accorder leurs violons dans
l'espoir de réduire la production à
hauteur de 10 millions de barils par
jour les autorités saoudiennes
ils voient un moyen d'ouvrir la voie à
je cite un accord équitable qui
rétablira l'équilibré des marchés
pétroliers
est ce qu'une baisse de la production
est réellement possible non parce que
d'abord je vous dis les pays du golfe et
la russie n'ont absolument pas intérêt à
ce que les cours remontent pourquoi tout
simplement parce qu'ils éliminent un de
leur principal concurrent qui est lé qui
sont les états unis donc ils peuvent
faire semblant de discuter ça ça
n'engage à rien ils peuvent même faire
semblant de réduire leur production
mais vous verrez que dans quelques
semaines on s'apercevra que la
production a pas beaucoup baissé
ils savent très bien que si
y maintiennent les prix on va dire entre
entre 20 et 35
il élimine complètement le pito le
pétrole de schiste américain alors si
vous croyez qu'ils vont gêner moi je
crois pas eux sont un peu gagnant pour
l'instant sur les sciences et sur ses
courts la perde pas trop d'argent en
tout cas alors même si ça ne suffit pas
à équilibrer leur budget loin de là mais
ils ne perdent pas systématiquement sur
chaque baril 40 dollars et il met à
genoux les loscistes américains je pense
que c'est tout bénéfice pour eux pour
après où ils pourront allègrement fixer
les prix de du pétrole parce qu'il y
aura plus que en gros deux acteurs et
trois acteurs et on aura complètement
éliminés ce texte 7 actifs pétroliers
qu'est le schiste américain je vous
rappelle qu'on avait fait une émission
il ya quelques mois où je disais
justement bien avant le corps en un
virus que pétrole irait à 25 dollars
alors je me suis trompé
c'est vrai il est allé avant mai
pourquoi parce que la demande ne faisait
que se ne faisait que se réduit alors là
où ça là où vraiment il ya un problème
pour les pour les américains c'est que
je vous rappelle tout de même que depuis
2008 le schiste américain avait embauché
pas mal de monde et que il y avait des
véritables écosystèmes c'est à dire des
villes entières qui se mettaient autour
des puits qui se crée autour des puits
et évidemment avec toute sa cohorte
d'emplois dans les services extérieurs
au tour de ceux de 7,1 du stip
industries pétrolières qu'est ce qui va
se passer
il va se passer que l'on voit déjà un
certain nombre de banques régionales qui
font faillite plus d'ailleurs qu'en 2008
et en 2009 donc ça veut bien dire que ça
c'est d'aller très vite et que ça
impacte très vite le tout ce qu'il ya
autour de cette industrie pétrolière et
que donc on va avoir un très fort
ralentissement de ce côté là qui va
impacter je vous dis les services qui va
impacter énormément le nombre de
chômeurs aux états unis et donc une
récession comme on en a rarement vu
de ce côté-là de l'atlantique à oualidia
justement pour revenir sur ces problèmes
de stockage si vous dites que la baisse
de la production est impossible et quid
du stockage qu'est ce qu'on fait de tous
et de tout cet or noir
alors je vous dis pas que la baisse de
la production est impossible mais je
vous dis je je pense que il ya un petit
jeu en ce moment qui fait que certains
pays profitent du fait que c'est pas eux
qui l'ont déclenchée mais du fait que
les cours soient bas pour les maintenir
dans ces eaux là pendant peut-être si
suis moi ce qui permettra de d'éliminer
un concurrent de taille
là le l'histoire du du du pétrole et des
réductions de de quantité de pétrole mis
sur le marché il faut quand même savoir
que le le pétrole s'est pas c'est pas
votre baignoire d'accord donc vous ne
pouvez pas simplement on a pu en
tournant un robinet réduire le débit et
le ré augmenter quand vous voulez ça se
passe pas comme ça et est donc en
réalité souvent ces deux là comme
souvent on vous annonce des choses mais
c'est pas suivi d'effets très rapidement
pourquoi parce que ça se fait pas comme
ça et là aujourd'hui
vous avez ce que je vous ai dit de tous
les stocks terrestres sont quasiment
pleins vous avez des bateaux qui font
des ronds dans l'eau parce que ça permet
de stocker du pétrole des tankers qui
valent évidemment de plus en plus chères
sont pas fous et donc vous êtes vous
êtes à bloc par tout ça coûte très très
cher et donc le le pétrole la production
de pétrole va se réduire vous savez elle
va se réduire de fait parce que je vous
ai dit les les boîtes de schiste font
faillite donc il ya un certain nombre de
puits qui vont fermer
elle se fera naturellement il y aura pas
besoin de réduction de
de production de la part des pays du
golfe et de la part des des ruches par
exemple l'opep disent qu'ils veulent
réduire qui se réunissent pour réduire
la production à hauteur de 10 millions
de barils par jour c'est de la com pour
vous c'est du cinoche oui c'est du
cinoche c'est savait parler ce genre de
grandes réunions en général il ne s'y
passe pas grand chose les choses se font
en coulisses et en coulisses je suis pas
certain qu'ils aient une volonté extrême
ni des pays du golfe ni de la russie
deux de ces baies au diktat américain
elle allait bien on remarque la courte
pause on revient dans un instant
nous sommes avec philippe douste-blazy
ancien médecin ministre de la santé sous
la présidence de jacques chirac
est-ce que vous ne portez pas une part
de responsabilité comme tous les
ministres de la santé dont je fais
partie des gens extrêmement humble et
qui pensent que bien évidemment j'aurais
eu tous heures depuis le premier jour de
ma vie mieux quand on voit la gestion de
cette crise et une gestion d'urgence le
constat est plutôt catastrophique pour
un pays comme la france
lorsqu'on est dans une guerre ne se
connait offrons biais des question qu'on
peut se poser
il ya des questions conclut opposera
plus tard parce que c'est une
catastrophe sanitaire comme on n'en voit
jamais personne n'aurait pu penser que
nous serions aujourd'hui moment où je
vous parle en saturation des lits de
réanimation en seine-saint-denis a quasi
saturation sur l'île de france
la seule chose qui peut compter
maintenant c'est le confinement le
dépistage et le traitement et j'espère
que tu confinement sera remarquablement
fait parce que là la différence en
confinement moyennement fait et un
confinement très bien fait c'est des
centaines de l'hydre et à la salle
bienvenue dans ses cages si vous nous
rejoignez on parle aujourd'hui de la
crise du pétrole liée au corona virus
mais pas qu'eux alors justement olivier
un parmi à les causes de cette crise il
ya bien évidemment la pandémie on le
disait mais on peut citer aussi l aga
des prix que se livrent trois pays la
russie elle les états unis et l'arabie
saoudite lors de la dernière réunion de
l'opep en mars dernier à laquelle
participait une dizaine de pays dont la
russie sur proposition saoudienne moscou
fois refusé d'abaisser sa production à
ryad a donc riposté pour bien expliquer
pourquoi la russie at elle refusé de
réduire sa production
je vous dis pas ce que je pense que ils
ont profité de la baisse du prix du
pétrole
parce que yahvé récession donc pas ce
qu'il y avait moindre demande on se
disant que c'était finalement une bonne
affaire et je pense d'ailleurs que les
pays du golfe sont parfaitement en phase
avec ça et que je vous dis joue une
petite comédie qui permet de ne pas se
fâcher directement avec les américains
mais s'ils peuvent maintenir le pétrole
l'imaginé jusqu'à la fin de l'année
entre 25 et 35 dollars le baril eh bien
je pense qu'ils auront éliminer
totalement la concurrence américaine et
ça veut dire que les américains qui nous
claironnait il ya quelques mois qu'ils
allaient être indépendant
énergétiquement
ce seront encore trompés dans leurs
prévisions restent au niveau 1 sur les
états unis et concrètement l'impact sur
la sur leurs économies alors l'impact
elle est majeure parce que ce que je
vous ai dit c'est que vraiment